[Music]
you know i'm curious about something
which is uh like me you you came of age
in the 70s uh and and that was an era
when there were a lot of streakers in
sports yeah there was there was a song
about the streaker and then i guess last
night the cardinals game there was a
streaker every now and then someone
brings it back and runs out naked onto
the field second time at a cardinals
game this year i don't know what
but it's with the cardinals or st louis
or whatever the second time it's a very
erotic
town something about that arch
but in in the 70s when it was happening
seemingly once a week yeah there was an
incident and i always thought this was
an apocryphal story until i asked yogi
berra about this myself because you know
he was famous still famous for saying
things that don't come out quite the way
he intended but they're they're
brilliant right they don't come out
correct they're utterly brilliant in
their own unique yogi way so he's
managing the mets and there's a
streaking incident and the next day his
former yankee teammates whitey ford and
mickey mantle want to know all about it
and this is before the internet before
youtube no one's going to show up
no photographs no photo nothing but you
know rumors getting around about what
happened and so they asked him about it
he says you know damn this thing sixth
inning siever goes into his stretch and
here they come three of them stark naked
they run across the diamond disappear
behind third base naked as jaybirds
mickey says wow
were they men or women and i swear to
god yogi said you know
i couldn't tell they had bags on their
heads
[Applause]
that's perfect yeah so now i heard that
story for years and about 20 years ago i
say to yogi
tell me this really happened yeah yeah
it did
uh now is this right you you are going
to honor you're going to honor bob
euchre or you have just honored bob i
didn't know the timing of this they
unveiled a statue of euchre um mr
baseball long time voice of the
milwaukee brewers
um
more than a hundred appearances i think
with johnny carson yeah he was one of
johnny carson's uh best uh best guess uh
class i think we have a photo of that
sometime
tremendously they unveil a statue
alongside the statue of hank aaron you
know all-time home run king hank aaron
and there's euchre lifetime batting
average 200 right fourteen career homes
he's very self-deprecating right he made
his whole career his whole career based
based on that so we unveiled the statue
of euchre and i i checked his baseball
card usually on the back of a baseball
card it'll say hank aaron all-time home
run king or whatever on the back of
euchre's card they had to search for
some superlative it said bob once got
out of a rundown against the phillies
that's his old time statistic that was
it was kind of a rundown what was his
best moment now while you were you were
in milwaukee did you have a brat while
you were there are you a guy that likes
a brat yes yeah you know you try to stay
away when you make your your living in
ballparks you try and stay away from
ballpark food on a regular basis but if
you're in milwaukee the single best
ballpark item anywhere is the bratwurst
with secret stadium sauce first at
county stadium now at miller park so i
had
four bratwursts during game four of the
82 world series between the cardinals
and the brewers and word about this got
around
and i receive a letter from a guy in
stevens point wisconsin
named ma
pesh
and he includes a polaroid
and he must have weighed 350 maybe 400
pounds and ma pesch claims that he's the
all-time bratwurst eating champion he
says he's eaten 11 in a single game
and he wants to challenge me to a
bratwurst eating contest
now on a pound-for-pound basis the guy
weighs more than twice as much as i do
yes there's no way that i can compete
but i'm fascinated by his claim and he
thinks he can back it up by including
the box score of the game in which he
claimed that he consumed the 11. he's
going to give you the box for the game
as proof that he ate that many exactly
exactly that it was it was the orioles
and the brewers so you got the line
score the runs the hits the errors the
winning and losing pitchers and he
thinks that this proves right that he
ate 11 brats and then came the
postscript he said this was all the more
surprising to me and my friends because
prior to that day i had never eaten well
against baltimore